Hello Freak bitches,
this article that I want to talk problem.
We got here a transgender woman.
Um,
she was a woman.
She applied to an all male,
all female college,
well was Wellesley,
Wellesley College.
I used to actually,
uh,
no girl from Wellesley back in the does a,
um,
it's an all girls' campus and um,
so she applied for the college.
She was born a female but then decided to transition into,
uh,
she had a very hilarious,
this is hilarious.
Listened to the description of how she introduces himself herself,
whatever masculine of center.
Gender Queer.
Exactly,
exactly.
Yeah.
I,
I am in love with this story and I am in love with these kinds of people.
I am in love with people that are so fucking preposterous that they take
preposterous to an art form and they,
they,
they become living parody whether they like it or not.
Listen to what the fuck I just said.
She goes to a college,
she applies to an all girls college is super liberal.
All or all girls college.
She decides that she is transgender and decides that she wants to,
she introduces herself as masculine of center gender queer changes her name to
Timothy decided that she's Timothy and ask people to use the male pronoun when
referring to him.
Okay,
so welcome on campus until the day that she announced he announced,
okay t now,
whatever,
that he wanted to run for the school's Office of multicultural affairs
coordinator whose job is to promote a culture,
a culture of diversity now who you would think would need diversity more than
someone who is a transgender man.
You know,
I mean that's,
that's a,
a very small segment of the population and they're often maligned and you know,
this is a socially marginalized group and it would be nice for an open minded
liberal college to accept someone like this and to recognize what a perfect
person to be a part of our campaign.
Encouraging people to,
uh,
you know,
to,
to be more open minded and accept people.
No,
they attacked her because now they felt that she is a white man and they don't
want a white man in that position because of a white man is in that position.
Then they're supporting the patriarchy.
So there was three other candidates for the Gig,
right?
All women of color.
Wonderful.
If one of them,
when and then you got,
okay,
you know your problem solved.
You got a woman of color in that position.
Plenty of diversity there.
You're good,
right?
Eh?
No.
They all dropped out and then they stayed at,
they started an anonymous Facebook campaign encouraging people not to vote at
all,
to keep a white man from winning the position.
Ah,
this is amazing.
This is the left eating itself.
That's what's happening.
They're eating themselves.
It is a feeding frenzy.
I used to have Paranas.
Okay.
And one of the things about products is,
well,
one gets a limp.
They just Jack that motherfucker.
They are the most ruthless cunts.
One.
One Parana would just be,
you know,
sometimes you have a fish tank,
one fish,
we'll just start swimming weird.
They start swimming kind of half sideways for some reason.
You're like,
is that fish okay?
And you have to look at him like what's going on with that fish?
That shit didn't last in that tank,
baby.
No,
those mother fuckers are just,
they just started taking chunks out of them.
That's what's happening here.
The left is the,
they're turning on themselves.
They've run out of outrage.
They've made so many safe places.
They don't want anything to be safe anymore and they want to be able to go to
war over everything.
They're ferocious there.
Paranas their social idea Paranas and they're attacking a gender quail,
gender queer masculine of center man for not being diverse enough for being a
part of the patriarchy,
Bardo Woven board.
A woman lived as a woman.
Nope,
you're a white man now.
You fucking piece of shit.
You're a part of the problem.
I makes no sense.
It does make sense though.
It makes sense because it highlights what this movement is all about.
It's socially retarded.
People that are left alone to their own devices and they're just devouring each
other like zombies.
They just tearing into each other like,
like zombies that are trapped into a fucking room.
It goes,
Rah,
they just ripping each other apart.
You're not diverse enough.
You're not progressive enough.
Fuck you.
You're such a pig.
I'm triggered.
They just trigger each other left and right.
This is,
uh,
this is an onion article.
This is a fucking onion article and it's not,
this is the national review.
This is a goddamn onion article and it's not transgender woman can't be
diversity officer because she's a white man.
Now I mixed 0 million cents makes all the sense in the world that it's not a
fake article.
I mean,
that seems like 100% of fake.
It's perfect.
It's amazing.
It's beautiful.
It's a rose is a rose in a bad neighborhood.
It pops out of the concrete and it comes out perfect.
It's amazing.
This is art.
It's,
it's the universe creating art with our own folly.
That's what it is.
It's culture.
It's called,
it's,
it's people,
you know,
there's something that happens to people when you deny reality,
when you don't look at things objectively.
Like there's,
there's I think like priests that molests kids,
right?
Some of that has to be from suppression.
Some of it has to be probably they were abused themselves.
There's probably all sorts of,
but some of that perversion has got to come from suppression.
It's like the Catholic school girl thing that everybody knows.
You know,
when I was in high school,
there was no scientists in my fucking ninth grade class,
but we all knew the girls who went to Catholic schools were hose and why are
they host their hose?
Because everybody tells them they can't be a Ho.
Everybody's talking to them constantly about,
you are going to go to hell,
do not touch a man's genitals,
don't you do anything?
Those calls were freaks.
They were the biggest freaks and we all knew it.
It was,
it was.
There was no books on it.
There was no youtube videos that we could watch,
but we fucking knew it.
Man.
We all knew it and I think it's a suppression issue and this is suppressing
individual identity.
This is suppressing free speech.
This is suppressing objectivity.
You're not allowed to have unique or intertwined thoughts.
You're not allowed to share opinions with the left.
And with the right.
You're not allowed to.
You have to have,
and you're constantly worried about being called out.
You're constantly worried about being outed and doxed and called out and shamed.
Everyone's shaming people and attacking people.
And it's this fucking feeding frenzy.
I love it.
I'm happy.
I'm so happy when I read a story like this.
I would encourage this woman to fight to the death for her position.
Oh man,
she's a man now.
Fight to the death of that position.
I mean,
literally,
I want you to show up for school in a fucking an armor with a sword and let them
know that you are,
you are here because you are a warrior for diversity and you're going to,
you're going to take this to the very end,
to the very end of time.
Oh,
it's amazing.
This is an amazing story.
It's like one of the greatest stories the universe has ever told cause it's,
it's just,
and it highlights that store that we were just talking about where the,
um,
the thing that was up on the,
uh,
the thing earlier with the United States is like a powder keg.
This is like what we're talking about like entitled ridiculous people that they
don't live in reality.
You're,
you're,
you're not looking,
you're concentrating on nonsense.
But why are they concentrating on nonsense?
Because they don't have to worry about feeding themselves.
They don't have to worry about shelter.
They don't have to worry about being in Ohio,
have no fucking power for a week and everybody has to stay alive.
You can't get to work.
Everybody's like walking back and forth to each other's house.
Sharon food and going out and getting firewood together and dragging it back at
some little kids wagon.
That's what people do when they want to survive.
When,
when you want to survive,
you come up with ways that you could all work together.
When it's too easy to survive,
you start attacking people for nonsense and that's what the fuck is going on
here.
You've got a campaign to keep.
We're going to make sure that a white man,
it's not going to win this.
Like as if she's really a white man.
Why are we pretending that's a man left of Weird Gender Queer masculine of
center.
Shut the fuck up.
You're a girl,
you're a girl or a guy,
whatever you are.
Who cares what the fuck it was probably way more to this story.
She's just a big bitch and I like
eating too much pussy on campus.
They're all mad.
Yeah.
She always just too good at it.
She's too good at it.
But she's gender queer,
so that means I don't think you'd do anything.
I don't know what that means.
I don't even think they know what it means.
But you,
you ever heard of Pan Sexual?
There was a woman who was like,
she was making history.
This is hilarious.
This is a hilarious story.
She was making history cause she was the first Gen.
Oh,
she was the first pan sexual person to take office
pants.
What the fuck are you talking about?
What does that mean to me?
And she doesn't sexually identify.
She's not particularly sexually attracted to either race or either gender.
It's either one or both.
Miley Cyrus,
Miley Cyrus is pansexual.
Of course she is.
That's called being a freak.
Pansexual.
What exactly does that mean?
But go,
go find the politician.
First politician as pansexual.
It's just so stupid.
Pen Sexual politician.
Since like a new word for bisexual,
it's not even bisexual.
It's cause like they have to be special.
It has to be met.
Mary Gonzales,
Texas state representative identifies as pansexual in new interview.
First of all,
good for her.
Eat that pussy.
Suck that Dick.
Have a party.
Honey,
I'm not hating.
Do whatever you want,
but do we really have to make a new name for it?
Fucking Christ.
I and I,
I,
I posted something about this awhile back on Twitter and there was people that
were defending the term pansexual.
I'm like,
fuck you.
Fuck you for trying to muddy up the war.
Fuck you for having this on your mind unless you're mocking it.
Fuck you for taking this seriously.
Fuck you for this being an actual thing.
When you want to debate it,
how bad is your job?
How bored are you at work that you're sitting in front of your Twitter account
defending pansexuality you stop.
You stop.
I'm saying she could do it.
I have no problem with,
don't get me wrong,
but you fucking stop.
If you think you're going to defend that,
fuck you.
You need to go cut snow cuts.
No,
you need to go cut.
Trees need to go cut trees and shovel snow over Jamie's parents house in the
middle of the winter when the fucking power's off for a month.
That's what you need to do.
You need to dig Brian red bands,
mom out of the fucking woods.
Dig Out of the woods.
It's a mile dirt road back to that lady's house.
Get get going.
Fuck face.
That's like,
what does that,
how many thousand feet is a mile?
Five thousand five thousand plus feet of snow shoveling you fuck.
How much for the driveway do you remember that you remember that when you're a
kid,
you'd go to a lady's house and,
uh,
ma'am,
we're,
we're shoveling stone.
Well,
how much for the driveway?
Like,
oh,
we're going to need 20 for this one.
That's too much.
It's a long driveway.
Man was going to take us a couple hours.
Oh,
well that's just too much.
They would get mad.
Okay.